oh hello professor brian thanks so much
for joining ieee software baltic spot
cast
such an honor ah it's uh honor is mine
i've been following you for
six months or more now and listening to
your podcast uh as part of my
regular podcast diet thank you thanks a
lot
such honor so i would like to ask you
first how you would like to define
yourself
well i think firstly i define myself as
a father
and as a husband as a friend as a human
being
somebody who is curious about the nature
of the universe
somebody who is relentless and and
a scholar uh and someone who's very lazy
and doesn't doesn't get around to all
the things in all those categories that
i want to
but hopefully i'll have i'll have
more time as my kids grow up a little
bit more and it gets a little bit easier
but what i really love to do is learn
that's the thing i've always loved about
life my mother tells me since i was a
two-year-old i wouldn't sleep at night
and that comes in handy as an astronomer
that's interesting so actually i have a
lot of interesting things but i would
like to go back with a challenge
do you have any memories about your
childhood you're interested in science
or technology i was
very interested in science and
technology i grew up outside new york
city uh on long island it's called and
uh
in that area it was very kind of
peaceful very nature
uh filled with nature natural beauty the
ocean
and i was always mesmerized by the ocean
i love collecting
rocks and shells and kind of just
looking at them and seeing what kind of
patterns they make and
it's funny because my kids will do that
too nowadays they'll pick up a sand
dollar they'll pick up a
uh you know a jellyfish and they want to
see
what makes these things work and i think
the
interface between kind of the curiosity
that one has when one is young
can be translated into a career and i
often
i was asking one of my sons about this
yesterday
you know what are you what do you lose
track of time
doing so what in what activity that you
do
do you lose track and besides video
games or besides youtube
uh it's really he loves to read he loves
to
to think about big questions and he
loves to
uh kind of teach things so i said you
know we'll keep that in mind and
and maybe someday you will be interested
in something that
allows you to use that passion intense
passion
for your career and that's sort of what
i did i was i never thought i could
get paid to be an astronomer i mean who
who does that it's like uh
it's like getting paid to be a cookie
taster or something you know
and nobody's gonna pay me to do it i'll
do it for free uh
but uh but in truth if you follow your
passion and if you're really
um uh incredibly you know consumed and
you can't
not do it it's uh it's something that
could lead to a to a very valuable
career
i can't agree with that i think minister
and struggling with audi how you find
your passion and most importantly your
purpose
how you find that and if you can tell us
just
one example how you can find your
purpose in either science outside
science
yeah it's funny you know what i
it's hard to know your purpose looking
forward sometimes you only learn your
purpose looking backwards
and uh you know if i think about the
steps that
you know took in my life there might
have been a few pivotal steps that
defined my life
i think my purpose was always honestly
to be a father to be a husband i think
that's what i'm naturally sort of
inclined to do
and i would do um if they paid me less
than they already do
i would still be a father and a husband
and so i think that being a human being
being having a soul having a a desire
to to to connect to other human beings
that sort of natural that is sort of my
passion uh but
beyond that i never knew that you could
combine
a passion for talking to other people
for making
jokes as corny and unfunny as they may
be
but you could connect to the general
public who has such a thirst for science
for technology
people like you and me we are sort of
doing magic
arthur c clarke who is the um the
founding namesake of uc
san diego's arthur c clarke center for
human imagination where i am the
co-director
as well as the into the impossible
podcast which is one of his phrases he
said
the only way to know the limits of the
possible is to venture beyond them
into the impossible so i always ask my
guest and i'm going to ask you later
what you thought was impossible as a
young as a young child that
allowed you to then go past that
boundary into the impossible
for me it was um overcoming uh
rejection overcoming failure i didn't go
to the harvards
like uh like professor download darren
lepomi who's a big fan of yours too
and uh george whitesides who you've had
on your show uh but but i've i've had uh
you know i had a i had to make it a
different way and i never gave up
and i i just knew that my love of the
universe and answering big questions
would carry me on even when you know i
feel
my book title obviously losing the nobel
prize that's a spoiler i did not win the
nobel
prize uh but that wasn't a letdown to me
it was just another
another goal i always say to my students
in graduate school
i see them the uh the the the
reward for solving a problem in your
thesis
is a harder problem so it's like you
always do
the easiest stuff first you pick the
lowest fruit first so the harder
uh achievements are beyond your grasp
and they always should be and
no one really gets to the promised land
without struggle
so to speak yeah yeah indeed i agree
with you a struggle i think and pain is
part of life and
and you have to cope with that and makes
you grow and stronger
so that's really powerful but i'm
curious to ask about your father
um how will the relationship and how he
affected you i think you almost you know
most of the saudi you mentioned him so
how would the relationship and how he
affected
you yeah my father and i had a complex
relationship
here in the us it's common for fathers
and sons to
be competitive with uh with baseball or
football
and i was always good at that but i my
father and mother divorced when i was
very young
um something like six or seven years old
and then i didn't see my father for
15 years until i was in graduate school
i knew he was a scientist i knew he was
a great mathematician i knew he won many
awards
and achievements but i knew that he
never won the nobel prize
and so for me as a kid having some anger
towards him for you know having not been
in my life
estranged from my life for 15 you know
long painful years
during those formative years when a kid
is a teenager
you know falls in love for the first
time gets dumped for the first time
gets rejected from uh the colleges that
he wanted to go to
uh et cetera and it goes for girls as
well uh so
for me it was very painful and so i
wanted to supersede him
to exceed his accomplishments and i know
it's a very
small-minded aspect of my character but
i want to be honest that that was an
animating
impulse for me to win a nobel prize
would be to forever
prove my superiority as a scientist and
that was part of the motivation it
wasn't 100
it was part of it and that's the
psychological side of me
i admit i don't regret uh but it's not
something
that i would say i'm particularly proud
of
that's very interesting and uh i think
it's very complex at the same time
because
wasn't incentive for use as a
competition with your dad or
incentive to be like a curiosity
yeah yeah i got a lot of uh of of
character traits good and bad for my
father and
and especially for my mother mostly good
ones and she's still
uh alive my father passed away sadly uh
very young
but um but we had a good relationship we
were able to reconcile
towards the end of his life and develop
a very deep bond that
uh according to him was deeper than any
other
father and son because we kind of paused
our relationship
at age six or seven and then re resumed
it in
my twenties when i was mature when i was
getting a phd when i was interested in
physics he used to joke
i don't care about playing with kids
until they learn
linear algebra and you know um that's a
pretty high bar
you know for for anybody let alone a
little kid
so he was joking but the fact is that
um as you know when you're teaching or
when you're as an educator
it's always more fun to teach the more
advanced classes because
at that level the students know almost
as much as you and your job
is to have them effectively surpass you
and so i feel like that you know kind of
delay in our relationship meant he
didn't
have to have you know the the patience
to deal with me learning arithmetic and
then he could just talk to me about
group theory
and and uh and other advanced topics in
science and math so
i don't regret it i don't you know i'm
sure it could have been easier for me as
a kid and i wouldn't
wish that on on my worst enemy to go
through
you know the kind of childhood that i
had to go through because i was
a child of divorce but i had a lot of
great
great treasured memories from my father
as well so i think i get
a lot of that curiosity passion
anti-authority bias
um you know from my father yeah that's
wonderful
and i can assume you have also the
emotional side and that's i think leads
the question about
what's the motivation behind uh
austerity losing losing
number five spock i think that you said
that the same that you want to convey
that scientists are people
and scientists stereotype also neglect
the both of human qualities like
vulnerabilities and emotion so if you
can tell us about
why you started god's idea writing the
book what motivated you
so the book was written as uh as an
appeal
to to non-scientists really it's it's a
memoir
about what it's like to be a young
scientist and and
feeling like you're on the verge of a
great breakthrough and the emotions the
struggle the competition
that most people don't think about most
people get scientists wrong
in many different ways most people think
a scientist looks a certain way
has a certain upbringing has certain um
in
in you know intrinsic gifts and and will
say things like
i'm not i had professor jim jim gates
who's the past president of the national
society of black physicists
on my podcast multiple times he's the
president-elect
of the american physical society and he
wrote a book about einstein uh called
proving einstein right
and in that book he basically says you
know most people say i'm not einstein so
i can't be a scientist
no einstein wasn't uh einstein for most
of his life
it's only in retrospect that we realized
this and this is coming from jim gates
the father of super symmetry
this guy's a titan and he's like i'm not
as smart as that guy
but it doesn't matter because we have a
place we have a role to play
and i want to convey that to scientists
for the following reason my book
is written from the perspective of an
experimental scientist someone who
builds telescopes
someone who builds detectors i don't
build cool squishy robots but i build
really cool things that can peer back to
the beginning of the universe
potentially
all the books that were in existence
before my book
really portrayed the subject of the of
the cosmic microwave background
etc from a purely theoretical point of
view meaning
colleagues like um lisa randall
max tag mark uh i'm thinking of sean
sean
sean carroll sean um brian green
all these people are brilliant and
wonderful thinkers and yet
they come at it from the perspective of
a theoretical physicist
and from my perspective we needed
somebody that could explain how the
experiments work
and how the details of the instrument
work
and that was very gratifying to do that
and actually i had two people
you know endorsed the book that really
made a great uh
a big impact on me one was um uh
sir uh sir uh roger penrose
who just won the nobel prize and i
actually just had a couple of emails
with him today
he's going to come back on my podcast
i'm going to do a live question and
answer with him
and he he said it was an intriguing book
he learned something from my book i mean
that was incredible
uh the other one who gave a wonderful
blurb was lord martin reece
uh of cambridge so that's rival
university to oxford
and lord martin said you know this is a
great book i just wish it didn't talk
about the nobel prize
but actually you know the book has this
uh i don't know
i'm showing it for my video audience but
there's it's hard to see
uh hopefully everybody has it out there
but there's three chapters about the
nobel prize and the rest is about
being a memoir of my experiences
growing up trying to learn about
astronomy uh worshiping
heroes of of astronomy like galileo
and even nobel prize winners and how
does it feel to come
close to your goal whether it be uh
becoming a nobel prize winner or winning
the world series you know we just had
the world series here in america
and you know one team wins one team
loses now is the
tampa bay devil raise are they not as
good or they should they be shamed of
not winning or my padres here in san
diego of course not
only one team can win it and they can
only win it basically for one year
so what the next year they're not as
good you know so
my point is that you spend most of your
time experiencing headwinds adversity
uh challenge and so enjoy that ride
don't only focus
on the golden gilded idol of winning the
nobel prize for example
yeah that's wonderful but i would like
to ask you about your thoughts about
nobel prize because i think
you're not the only one that we have
recently witnessed some time and there's
a biases
in who will be awards award and nobel
prize and the percentage of women as
well
who have been awarded in 55 years ago so
if you can tell us
because you brought some solution for
that what do you think about
nobel prize in first place how the
committee
doing selection and can you tell us
about yourself about that
yeah well one of my friends pointed out
recently that since my book came out the
number
of uh female nobel prize winners in
physics has doubled
uh now it was only at uh at two
so it's not uh not super significant but
uh but
it's moving in the right direction and
just this year my friend
andrea guezz at the uh at the university
of california
los angeles which is not far from here
uh she won the nobel prize i'm hoping to
have her on my podcast
uh very soon too so having um
having excluded large numbers of
scientists throughout the years
the most common objection i get to the
nobel prize or or
in favor of the nobel prize is that um
you know they always do a good job and
scientists aren't biased
now i don't know about you maybe you've
experienced some bias in science i mean
maybe you've realized that scientists
aren't free of prejudice
free of judgment free of bias but i'll
take you back
to official records of the nobel
committee
back in the 1920s and the 19s
and you'll know of a scientist named
albert einstein we just talked about him
he came up with special relativity
theory in 1905.
he followed that up with an even greater
discovery in 1915
1912 to 1915 and between
1905 and 1922 when he finally received
the 1921 nobel prize
uh a gentleman by the name of gustav
delen
who is swedish won the nobel prize in
physics for an outstanding
discovery called the lighthouse
automatic gas accumulator
now i don't know how often you use a gas
accumulator there
in europe but i i've never used one
myself
and yet i use general relativity every
time i turn on my gps
um and without it it wouldn't work so uh
so now you have to ask why
was there an exclusion principle at work
uh
and in fact there was there was a man by
the name of philip lenard
and he was hitler's chief of aryan
science
and he didn't like people uh that were
jewish to get recognition in fact he
derided uh the science that einstein did
this cosmology this theoretical physics
they call that jewish science and they
said it was antithetical to aryan
physics
and that they had a rule because if you
won a nobel prize
you could nominate the winners of all
future nobel prizes
so lenard was on was the chief of
hitler's aryan physics
um uh campaign and so for many years
they
basically made a pretext that einstein
you know didn't develop anything worthy
of the nobel prize but secretly they
said einstein must not win a nobel prize
so now ask yourself philip leonard won
the nobel prize
uh in 1904-1905 i believe
and he won it for the discovery of the
photoelectric effect
which is what einstein in part would
would win the nobel prize for in 1921.
uh so now between those times i mean he
was a smart person
i mean uh william shockley won the nobel
prize for the invention the transistor
and advocated for what's called eugenics
he wanted to eliminate the
the preponderance of african americans
and so
you can have great scientists that are
also terrible human beings
and so my perspective is the nobel prize
by not rectifying
its past sins it has committed sins
against science against the history of
science it has excluded people
and it continues to do so and i claim in
the book
it will do so at its own peril at some
point the nobel prize will either
rectify and have redemption or it will
cease to be as prestigious as it is now
that's really
very important point i would like to
stop here again about what you mentioned
about being great science but maybe
you're
a terrible human being and first the
question also here because i think
how do you think maybe psychopaths or
sociopaths
will be in that position like bi
and having responsibility for life as
opposed to accident phd
or maybe being a committee for deciding
who will win or not
and he's i think you had a sort of
professor gentry patrick i think in
about trace and diversity in science and
i think that's something very important
but i would like to stop here again
because when i see the comments about
the subject about
race diversity or inclusion and
diversity
some people think that science is
science and you don't have to speak
about this
point is some people assume in academia
and accounting that it's just
a cosmetic image so if you can tell us
about
why they think some people in the
academy think
inclusion and diverse doesn't make sense
and don't believe in
in that subject and you also mentioned
that human also can be have
implicit prices and explicit prices if
you can just
have houses really complicated if you
have someone who's psychopaths
and biased and and we still have this
issue but i don't know what you think of
the solution for that
for for this problem yeah
no it's a legitimate question and it's
funny because i'll have people my
podcast is not political i don't talk
politics
i'll have on people on the far right the
far left i won't have on you know
someone who's
really odious psychopath sociopath uh
but i will have on
uh both sides in equal abundances
i think science is very liberal nowadays
there are you know people of all
different
genders of all different orientations of
all different colors of all different
backgrounds religions etc
but it is such a hot button issue that
it's almost impossible that people won't
be offended by
one guest i have on versus another guess
so that's that's just a
an issue that we played now i've had on
uh since we've had in america the black
lives matter movement
uh and uh and great agitation for
positive changes
to a very bleak history in america and
science
um uh and and i think what my what i've
tried to do
is is make it human make it humanize
what the struggles are
of these african-american men and women
in particular mostly
scientists um you know and and uh
haven't gotten in you know political or
whatever
but to see that they actually do face a
different struggle than i face now i
might face a different struggle than
somebody else face you might face a
different struggle than somebody
i think science is getting better uh for
example we have
explicitly uh policies meant to
encourage and increase the enrollment of
african americans at this campus
that is counteracted and it has been
successful under our chancellor pradeep
kosla
we've more than doubled the number of
african americans in just five or so
years that's a historic accomplishment
but it's three percent
it's up from 1.5 percent um that's not
enough
and uh and what will happen marwah
that's so frustrating is that we're
doing so good we're attracting these
brilliant people
and then we're a public university uh
and we don't we're not that old we were
only founded in 1960 that was 11 years
before i was born
it's not like it's a you know this
university like harvard that goes back
300 years and what happens sadly
from my perspective is that we cultivate
and we get these
extremely um you know talented people of
all different
races colors and creeds uh but often a
public
a private school like stanford uh will
come along and say well thank you very
much for identifying these wonderful
candidates
we have uh you know 42 billion dollar
endowment
uh versus you know san diego has 700
million
uh it becomes almost impossible to
retain attract uh
retain the people it's a very very
difficult um
problem also being a young university we
don't have
alumni going back to the 1800s like
berkeley or ucla or to the 1600s in the
case of harvard and
if you went to harvard you know like
professor lapommy my good
friend you will have a higher chance of
your kids going to harvard someday and
and that's by design so if you're
african american same too
my friend chanda prescott weinstein
she's a professor at university of new
hampshire
um you know if she has children i don't
know what what her situation is but
they could have a higher chance of
getting into harvard because she went
there
and that means that just because there's
there's only so many
you know these wonderful students to get
that we would
unfortunately not be as competitive and
that's just a reality
but again we have to work harder and we
are
yeah that's a good point but i would
like again ask you about how the academy
structure i mean
you said in your book about this like
hunger game
and um and that's sad because i think
yeah
you write for advances but still we have
issue about
this power disparity for example i would
like to stress again about the mental
health
issue because i think you came across
again as someone who's care about
other human beings not only science just
and neglect emotions
and i also think it's a story if your
supervisor andrew lynch had this beside
and 2010 and you don't know why he did
that
um but do you think because of the
pressure in academy you have a lot of
pain amount of work for the week 60
hours you have
work yeah
yeah that's a very good question you
know the academia never turns off
it's not like i teach three hours a week
and that's it
no i'm in the classroom three hours a
week i'm preparing 18 hours a week
i'm advising my four graduate students
you know 20
other hours of the week i've got a
family i've got responsibilities we've
got committees i've got to hire people
we have to serve on awards coming we
have to serve on
uh admissions committees it's it's it
never ends if i wanted to
i could work uh 24 hours a day seven
days a week
but the most important thing for my
sanity and i do want to say very briefly
after my book came out
in the fall of 2018 a man uh
who's thought he was in the running for
the nobel prize in economics
took his own life after finding out
uh that he did not win the nobel prize
for very similar work
this is for work revolving around global
warming i believe
um climate change and and economics and
we can't say that losing the nobel prize
caused him to commit suicide but his
friends said he was despondent
about that and it took place right after
the announcement so
i do feel like i i as i say i don't know
if if my
beloved advisor andrew lang took his
life in any way because he was
overlooked
it is ironic in some sense his ex-wife
won the nobel prize in chemistry last
year
uh francis arnold are in 2018.
and uh that's uh they were certainly a
power couple
and i'm very happy for her uh she's gone
through great pains too
and it's just amazing you know she lost
a son she had breast cancer she lost
her ex-husband who she was close to uh
the father of her children
and so um how do some people react one
way and others react another way
it's it's hard it's hard to understand
but getting to your point of the hunger
games yes it never turns off
and for me i force my students to turn
it off i
i say i don't want you i want you to
work six days a week
but you may not work seven days a week
uh first of all it's against my religion
uh judaism to make people work uh seven
days a week because
we our tradition is that uh working
seven days a week no matter how rich you
are you could be jeff bezos you could be
bill gates you could be the richest man
in the world and if you work seven days
a week
our tradition teaches us that you're a
slave and that the human being should
never be a slave
you're a slave to no one but god and
that you're not even a slave you're a
servant but you're
you're you have free will and that the
way that you exercise it is in my mind i
turn off my phone
i turn off work i don't answer emails i
don't do podcasts um
and these are things i love it doesn't
feel like work but still
if i don't take a sabbath a rest once a
week
who is in charge of my life at this this
device
i don't want that to be the case so in
my mind
that's the way i hope i teach my
students
to have a some amount of work-life
balance
now the other side of it um in the old
testament in the in the torah
it says that six days a week you must
work
so in other words it's set it doesn't
say like you you could work six days a
week but you have to take off saturday
because what if you don't work any day
of the week
then saturday means nothing to you um
and so it says you must work meaning
not that you're a servant but that you
are passionate and that you are
researching you're reading about
astronomy in my
students case you're learning about
physics you're learning about history
about philosophy um six days a week and
it should consume you as a graduate
student because if it doesn't
uh then you know it's it's actually a
good thing you might find this is not
the right track for your life
i really like that when you combine a
religious perspective like you just
in in science and that's really
it's great to find this discussion to be
honest in different land i'm i'm not
making a sweeping generalization that
we miss this point and i that leads the
question about publish and parish model
in academy
you know you say that you have to work
from six days that this pressure
everyone i speak with i am pressured to
publish and when i
see that if you want to make convention
in like 50 years ago you can see
who when nobel prize they just maybe
intuitively you don't have
this amount of publications you're just
focusing in the resigns
how do you say publish and parish model
comes from and how we can
make it perish yes that's a
that's a a very good point uh you know
it's not that old it's not that long
it's not like um
you know galileo was publishing in
journals etc most of the time they were
publishing books a lot of times they
were popular books
uh newton obviously and then you know
finally they had the royal society and
eventually they had nature
magazine was really the first journal
and i always point out you know there's
there
many instances where someone like
einstein after he won the nobel prize
he would write a letter to the editor he
would say you know um
actually a few days ago a young man
named mr mandel came to my office and
asked me a question
and this is what i thought about it and
then he went through what's called
weak gravitational lensing which he
thought would never be
detectable like many things he said were
wrong and mistaken
because we ended up dude that we did
detect them uh in fact we measure them
with the observatory picture
behind me at the simon's observatory uh
is going to measure that and then we
already have with many of the
instruments there
currently uh and so uh it's funny great
people can have great flaws
and uh certainly einstein did he was not
rumored to be a great father to his kids
i wasn't there for him now he didn't
have this publisher perish
he made a lot of um you know great
accomplishments younger in life and
and then later in life was kind of a
little bit
too overcome as my colleague sabine
hassenfelder says
by being lost in math trying to you know
find a theory of everything from purely
mathematical principles essentially
uh but the work uh the publisher parish
model is not that old
i think a lot of it is going aside
because of
media like this i had on you know the
other day
sean carroll professor sean carroll of
cal tech in pasadena and we talked about
a recent result an abstract
that we both read about what's called
cosmic birefringence it's not so
important it was submitted to physics
review letters which is arguably a top
one or two
impact factor journal a result of many
many years of work by
ichiro camazo and his student uh
co-worker miami
and utah miami um and that work
generated a lot of controversy and then
so we started to
analyze it but because it wasn't put on
the archive which is an open source uh
free publication no barriers no hurdles
no hunger games
uh we couldn't analyze it because it's
not public
and i think that model is gonna go away
i don't think i think
the journals like nature like science
they're gonna have to adapt
that science is done nowadays by people
working
uh you know in in in large groups and
working
on very important projects and this idea
that you have to put the stake in the
ground
or else you won't win the nobel prize
should it arise in some cases
um as it did for me i think that model
is
is is going to eventually be replaced
and so
i don't think it has much longer before
it in its current form perishes
and also before the nobel prize perishes
in its current form
unless it enacts some of the ref
reformation that
that i've proposed in many many other
people including nobel prize winners
i've had on my show like adam reese
say they agree with this and nobody
disagrees with it which is the strange
thing
why don't they change it if all these
people including nobel prize winners
agree it needs to change yeah that's uh
also a good mind
and i mean chris asks this question do
you think if nothing
changed in maybe 10 years they think we
have to think about something beyond
academy and industry that's a new
institution because i think even eric
wanted stein
this question if we have to find
something beyond academy and industry
something completely new
do you think about that we can make up
with new
ideas beyond academy this new
institution new structures
i think it's possible i think right now
we have this kind of
educational government complex in the
united states where
most of the funding to do a project like
the simon's observatory is a 100 million
dollar project
that i am you know privileged to co-lead
with uh with
many other colleagues at penn princeton
berkeley
and elsewhere and this project couldn't
happen without
uh without private funding in the case
of the simon's foundation
uh and on our other projects polar bear
which is also pictured
behind me and alma pictured way in the
distance over there
those are billion dollar class or the
alma is at least
a billion dollar class observatory
couldn't be built without you know
universities without large scientific
foundations
that back it so i think in experimental
science it's it's unlikely to change
in um in in terms of you know projects
with the theoretical side like eric
is talking about uh frequently and by
the way he says hi to you
as well as uh ben shapiro asked me to
send you
uh uh a hello uh so you have fans that
you don't even know and maybe you'll
never meet maybe you will
uh but uh but i told them that you
follow them both and
uh and and i think uh i think it's a
sign
that media like this are gonna be more
prominent and that we are going to
you know basically have an overwhelming
uh
obligation because if you want to get
funded outside of the academic
industrial complex
uh then you need to bypass it you need
to go to the people that are actually
paying for it right the nsf in america
and the crc
in europe or whatever they don't have
millions of dollars
they get it from taxes and who pays
those taxes as well as the citizens
and so if you and i and others like us
and eric if we can take our message to
the citizens
that will start a groundswell and that
will say hey look
marwah alduin is doing this amazing work
or eric weinstein's doing this amazing
work
why not support it and maybe we'll need
to have you know like
patreon for physics account you know or
what have you i don't know but
i wouldn't have predicted you know what
10 years ago that
someone like me could be talking to
someone like you
instantaneously across the continent and
then tens of thousands of people will
hopefully
see our conversation and share and
benefit from it so
i believe there are opportunities and
it's going to take a smart
young person maybe not young i don't
know to think of a model
outside of the academic industrial
complex
i think that's really wonderful question
about the broadcasting
into impossible broadcast and i i first
before asking the motivation i think i
listened to the professor gatz uh sarah
and nearby costa and he said that
how the effect of both costing or
youtube can influence people in
maybe under privileged countries and
that's really
powerful if you look for replication and
you look for the broadcast
and the influence of that so if you can
tell us about the motivation for your
broadcast
why do you think maybe broadcasting can
be a life changing experiences for
people interested in science because
some students cannot really
afford the fees for studying yes yes
i've had that thought a lot especially
with kovid
that um the the model of education needs
to change
and again these are all existential
threats if if
academies don't react and uh and take
the challenge and just try to keep the
old
way where there's a professor on zoom
talking to a class on zoom
that that's that that's going to be the
end of academia as far as i'm concerned
we need to be active we need to be uh
doing uh
doing virtual reality doing augmented
reality i mean as i said uh professor
i'm not professor dr peter diamandis
came on my show
at the beginning of the pandemic and i
said to him look i'm a pretty good
teacher but
i'm not as smart as galileo or you know
isaac newton
or you know people of that nature and
wouldn't my students like to talk to
them i mean how
how cool would it be to talk to them or
have them here
have them directly there and there's no
reason that you can't
uh and some say that we are in a
simulation i don't want to talk about
that yet but
but but the fact is we have the
technology nowadays with oculus with
with very inexpensive things much
cheaper than a textbook
uh an oculus is cheaper than some of my
textbooks that are used in university
so we have to adapt or again it's going
to be an existential threat
to the to the academy look the academy
has been in place
uh there was a university in egypt in uh
i think the year
1000 and then there was a university in
bologna in italy
in in the year 1082 and essentially it
was some
guy standing up and scratching a piece
of rock on a blackboard another rock
and that hasn't really changed that much
in a thousand years now
how many other things haven't changed in
a thousand years very few
and so if we don't change it that's the
risk and so
i agree with with professor sad and and
and people like eric
um who are reaching into and thinking
about different approaches
and including going popular like gad has
been on
uh the joe rogan experience uh
eric's been on that many times and eric
says to me like i don't think that
people are going to understand
the you know 14-dimensional hop
vibration that's present
in his theory of everything but um but
physicists are terrible at using
the public relations material that they
have
and by him going on joe rogan 9.4
million people
saw a fiber bundle you know for the
first probably the only time they'll
ever see it do they understand it
absolutely not
and he knows that but to show them that
and maybe they'll be
0.1 you know you'll get 10 000 people
kids interested in the hop vibration
if maybe only to prove them wrong but
but still
marwa isn't that a magical thing and so
i always think back i had on carl
sagan's daughter
sasha sagan she wrote a book i had on
his widow andrewian who's the cosmos
next generation series producer and
writer and
both of them i reminded that carl said
he said once that a book is proof that
humans can work magic
a book is the words of the of an author
who might have died
centuries ago and you're hearing their
voice in your head today
now you and i this conversation will be
available for generations
and so i say nowadays a podcast is proof
that human beings can work magic
yeah that's really wonderful point and
uh i agree with everything you said yeah
and if you can tell the best about um do
you think ego sometimes
is important um as your science is
important
yeah i i definitely do again uh you know
i'm very i'm very
influenced by my judaic culture and in
judaism
we believe we have two different
inclinations we have an inclination to
do good
and we have an inclination to do evil
remember i don't know if you ever saw
these cartoons it'll be like a little
devil over here
a little angel over here and that's kind
of the way we think about it so but
sometimes
it's it's some of each and i think this
is like the chinese yang yang symbol
within the black there's a bit of white
within the white there's a bit of black
we have a hybrid nature we have a
dualistic
spirit uh whether and i don't care
people believe or not that's really not
i'm not
proselytizing i don't care but that
sometimes your inclination to achieve
to win a nobel prize uh sometimes that
can do good
even though at heart i believed it was a
form for myself
of idolatry of worshiping idols a gilded
graven
image that literally has a picture of
alfred nobel that you bow down to in
front of a king to receive
in my mind there's one king and it's not
on earth
and so thinking about uh the but but
still we can do great good
and i don't i don't criticize the people
that want it and i think you know i just
talking to
sir roger penrose winner of the 2020
nobel prize in physics
he's worked for 70 you know 50 60 years
work with stephen hawking
he's using the prestige of the nobel
prize to advance his cosmological model
and now he got a paper accepted that had
been rejected for many many years
i wonder why that is marwah isn't that
interesting uh and i'm hopefully going
to work with him
you know to look for trying to prove him
wrong and i've told him this to his face
i said roger
i don't think you're interpreting the uh
analysis of bicep 2 data properly
but i love you i love what you do
and i want to help you and even if it
means proving you're wrong and he's all
for it
so i think that's the good that can be
done
from an ego from a from a perspective
not of haughtiness because no good can
come of that
but instead of honest use of
the gifts blessings and prestige that
you have
i think good can come of it yeah yeah of
course let's give
you also because i i know you don't have
too much time how you deal with
criticism because i thought that if
you know some people just for iroquois
for example
and steven uh well from there's a lot of
controversy about they are not science
uh yeah
i mean not an academy story so and some
people don't accept
their social ideas and you are open
about that you open for discussion
how do you deal with criticism because i
think you have something about
how you communicate with public and for
example and science communication
and how you accept people outside
academic have a discussion because
that's all something i think i i
respected what you're doing that you
have open platform
for anyone who discussed science yes as
long as it's legitimate as long as it's
not you know
biased or prejudiced or they have some
some really odious ideas
i will investigate it and i now have a
platform
that um with many many treasured fans
and people that subscribe
and that i love and i engage with every
single one of them
and now it's gotten to the point where
i'll have nobel prize winners asking me
to come on my podcast
and i don't think that lightly and i'm
not saying oh they're the best i'm the
best because i have a nobel prize look i
wrote a book that kind of criticizes it
but the point is that that
um these people deserve respect and the
very first question you asked me was a
very important one how do i define
myself
and remember i said you know besides
father and husband curious
and passionate and scholarly i love to
learn
i feel like learning is like when you
were a kid you probably play with legos
or
you probably played with the with the
puzzles i did and i
always love solving it and then breaking
it apart and then doing it again because
the the thrill of the solution is just
so magical
and and it is allowing us to take
ourselves away from the pain
that daily life presents us and really
get back to that purity of when we were
children
exploring children are natural
scientists i always say they're
naturally curious they're passionate
i've got a lot of kids and i love them
all
and and i see them playing and then i
say well they're kind of like scientists
too because they're jealous
they're petty they don't play well they
want their possessive
of their toys they won't share even i
have twins and they fight like
you know they're strangers sometimes and
why is that
um and it's funny because the girl kind
of dominates the boy it's kind of cute
uh but but anyway the point that i'm
making is that
let's let's let the the beautiful
aspects of
childlike wonder of scientists bloom and
so
i when i talk to these scientists it's
like i'm talking to i see them as little
kids
i see uh professor sarah seeger of mit
and she's talking about life on venus
and yeah she's taking a lot of heat and
criticism for it
and but i see the playfulness in her
eyes and i'm hoping to have her on my
podcast talk about her book
where she talks about her childhood
let's let's let's try and take some
some of the good aspects of childhood uh
you know without the petty criticisms
but take the honest ones and
and in that way get back to the purity
the essence of science
engineering and math that's great so
it's a question and we
end because i know you don't have so
much time i would like
you what may be the most important
quality you have to maintain well-being
in academy something you have to
maintain for the journey in academy
i think it's i think it's a long journey
and i think you cannot do it if you
don't
love the work that's why i kind of use
as a test when i'm interviewing a new
grad student and i say what do you do in
your free time
and i love to hear well i climb you know
rocks and i go skiing and
those are great those are important um i
i
really am delighted when i hear i read
brian greene neil degrasse tyson i read
popular science i read
you know karl popper i r you know
whatever um i
love learning when i'm uh when i'm you
know just
lounging around i'm learning about
science or i used to work
on my car you know one of my uh students
she her
her parents have like a manufacturing
business that she used to work in
and she loved tools and she's an amazing
now she's a professor herself and how
amazing is that
not only that marwah she has a graduate
student uh a female graduate student
herself
that's now the 19th generation of my
academic tree that i can trace back to
1597.
this is all because she's an incredibly
passionate person her graduate this is
darcy baron at the university of new
mexico
and her student kayla and having them in
this chain
is an awesome responsibility for people
like me and you
because um in the russian language the
word uh scientist
and i think it holds for engineer too
but the word scientist means
someone who was taught it means that you
and i
receive teaching it may not have been
perfect but we were taught
that means we have an obligation if we
are scientists to create new scientists
we must teach
so i'd say the most essential quality is
to be a good teacher you need to be a
good
student and to be a good student you
need to be relentlessly
passionately curious that's wonderful
and lastly what was this advice was
given to you with a personally
professionally
and was life changing uh i i think for
me
the the most life-changing advice that i
had uh
you know really came from a rabbi and
it sounds strange because he's not a
scientist but it was that
there's more to supporting a family than
than just making money there's
more to the um to the process of being
a leader with your with your life
partner with your spouse
um husband wife whatever uh there's more
to that than just making money
and and having having you know financial
stability
you have to have intellectual you have
to have spiritual stability
you must be a leader in uh your family's
course both you and your partner and
because children
need that they need that stability they
need they they crave
stability and innocence protecting their
innocence
it's so incredibly important to me and
if you can preserve their innocence then
you will preserve
the bandwidth the the resources for them
to be curious and not have to worry
about
their parents yelling and fighting in
front of them as i did
and the other challenge is that many
kids have far worse than i did
so for me the best advice is is strive
to be a leader of your family
in your community be a mentor and uh and
be teachable
be coachable and in that way you will
succeed
that's really wonderful and i think
that's the core for me problems
how you have a good human being so i
want to know
uh three things in your field what
is the key core finding of soft robotics
um first of all that appeals to you and
what's like the um
what's like the theory of everything in
your field in our field
it's you know particles make up the
universe they interact by forces and
fields
um and and they comprise the the largest
structures in the universe
for you what drew you to robotics and
then what is the
animating principle of soft robotics
yeah that's really wonderful question
because i think that's
the debate of the field because as you
may know soft robotics idea that we
wanted to go from traditional robots
which is rigid
and maybe sometimes not safe for human
interaction we want to make
safe soft problems however no
misconceptions
because not every soft problem is safe
if you imagine you have like a build or
something from very elastic material
and very high speed it will cause harm
but if you ask about what is really the
core or maybe everything i think that's
the debate we have in the field
if we have to make a soft material
do we have to understand the physics of
this material and is this material
intelligent
i mean that should we use passive
material like silicon which is available
over the shell
everyone can use it or we have to design
smart material that can compute its
intelligence
and can have actuation and sensing so if
we look at the nature like
if we see inspiration from the nature
how these animals or the creature move
and actually
and heal and grow their parts this is
all inspiration
but that's the debate here as robotics
you see
that sometimes that's the debate we have
even in the broadcast
what is the missing missions between
material science who develop the
material
and the and and also robotics because i
think if you wanted to design for
example
um a finger like like human beings so
ask yourself what kind of material i
have to use
it's as best as material and i have to
use like motor and actuate it with a
cable and make it bending and deform in
such a way
and for me because i have this
experience work in smart material and
what i mean a smart material is
for anyone who's not in the field that
this material can
have responses towards stimulus it could
be stimulus to the light it can be
responsive towards the heat it could be
voltage
and when you this material have stimulus
they can get responses like mechanical
performance
so that's a question here how we design
them how
we can design this material to have to
have a function
like actuation or sensing so that's i
think for my humble bear for you that
the core point here is a material
science and if we understand the physics
of the material and how we can use this
material in a certain way
so that we can design a finger
or a trunk or any function so
that's i think the core and uh it
sometimes is underappreciated because as
you know in robotics we don't have so
much
expertise in material and that's make a
gap between the communication between
material science and robotis so now
there's a trend that we need to make
like material robotics so they have the
both knowledge impulse field so
and then you can if you understand what
you do you can design reproducible
robotics of robotics
with the function you're looking for so
the pure answer is the material science
i think
however some uh robust don't think about
that so you still think
um i just it's too technical here but i
think
that's the debate stay in the field uh
whether we have to understand the
material but i think everything starts
from
understanding the physics of the
material and how to model them
and have a descriptive model and then
you can design what you want
given an application and what drew you
to it did you have an influence as a
child were you the kind of kid that was
playing with blocks with legos with
animals i don't know what what drew you
to it and what
keeps you invested through the
challenges of being a young academic
i think that's a good question i have to
be honest um maybe i'm not the best one
who can answer this question because i
didn't have a lot of
exposure for that i was more interested
in
art and and drawing but i i think in
in school i have low self-esteem i
didn't even believe in myself at all and
maybe
because i was the first engineer in my
family and
i had a lot of rough time and childhood
to be honest i didn't enjoy it so
maybe that's hard but i think i came to
understand that
i'm really fascinated by mathematics for
example in high school
and physics and that's make me a lot of
posting confidence
and i think yeah that's yeah maybe
sometimes it could be uh
you know a turning moment my life in
high school that i i can't do it i i am
fascinated by biomathematics
and and also biology so yeah sometimes
you can't discover you
me i don't say super power but sometimes
as this earlier i highlighted that how
childhood plays significance rule i
think that's absolutely right
and the teacher as well play significant
rule so if the teacher is so something
in you and encourage you
that's really the momentum for your life
and do you
uh do you feel like it's an obligation
for you to someday become a teacher
what are your aspirations in terms of
extending and leveraging
your accomplishments to benefit the
world yeah that's a good question
actually i
i i'm holding a ten-year academic
position in my home country
correct it's different from us in europe
and actually i lived that i'm not
specifically leave
but i left it just because i want to
have a
more expertise and also i wanted to like
i consider the freedom i love freedom
and what i mean about freedom i don't
like so much politics incorporating
academy
so yeah maybe it's risky for me because
i know when i came that everyone is
looking for junior but i wasn't in your
it was for me like a prison
i know it sounds crazy for people but
yeah i know it's it's security but
sometimes if you're in a position and a
place an environment
doesn't match what you're looking for
sometimes you can take a risk and maybe
it
can makes you go to places you never
expect it to be
maybe it's risky i know some people said
it's crazy but that's me yeah
that's a beautiful way to put it i love
teaching so much yeah
yeah you have a natural a gift for
teaching i've listened to many of your
podcasts uh the ieee
soft robotics podcast last question that
i asked all my guests and i
i know i'm your guest but it's kind of a
uh what do we call it a swap
you know in america they there's two tv
shows and they'll cross
over um i want to ask you uh sir arthur
c clarke said
that the only way to find out the limits
of the possible is to venture
a bit beyond into the impossible and
that's how i came up with the name of
the
podcast for the arthur c clarke center
for human imagination
i want to ask you as a younger person
maybe 10 20 years ago
just starting your academic career what
seemed impossible to you maybe about
life
faith whatever what seemed impossible to
you
that now seems possible through the lens
of time and looking back
i think that's really profound and
wonderful question and
i think um i'm really admired the
aspects that you're concerned about
how the scientists have to be
highlighting the emotional side
i for me i struggled a lot i struggled
yeah everyone is struggling but i think
for me because i i lost my mom
when i was 19 and that was a shock from
traumatics this older so it was hard for
me and
i also take care of my family and i
become ill
for a certain time and then at i'm 29
now it's at age 26
my grandma she used everything for me
and she also passed away
and that was for me and my relationship
with my father
he i respect him but it wasn't really
great but i think that's something to be
honest i struggle with because
yeah you wanted to do something but
sometimes the time
and events happen in your life is like
dragging you
and you try to challenge that it is hard
it is hard because everyone
everyone has a story and but sometimes
it's so hard and
you just want to hit something and yeah
it's just maybe it's a growing process
because i learned
how to be happy with myself
most of time i i just maybe not happy
but uh i'm i think i learned that how to
accept being by yourself being
independent
i think life is uh listen to the great
experiences and
i think to answer the question how to
bush is impossible i think one of the
thing is that
i like it that imagination if you have
imagination i want to be in a certain
place
i wanted to achieve that and i remember
i remember vividly that i was telling my
late mom that
i don't want to be an ordinary girl i
want at something and
that's maybe i'll look ordinary for
people but
inside me i'm not ordinary girl and
maybe i'm not smartest because i know
there are many smart people i'm just
trying to learn as you mentioned i want
to learn because there's a lot of things
i want to learn
but i think the most important thing and
that's uh a quote from the book of
the power of positive thinking of
non-medicine appeal that
positive pattern assault can change
effect and
i think that's really powerful if you
imagine something in a good way
and you want it so much especially it
could be impossible
it would be possible because of the
positive pattern result so i think
that's related to energy as well
yeah so that's how i think uh
the answer for me now about the
impossible
support yeah wonderful yeah i love that
you connected to imagination as a
arthur c clarke uh center for human
imagination
all of our curiosity goes in that
direction marwah you are
an inspiration you are destined for
great things i follow you
and i listen to you i learn from you
keep up
the wonderful work on the ieee soft
robotics podcast
and i hope we can do it again maybe uh
in a little while and
uh maybe someday we'll do a we'll do an
actual live stream
in person i would love to meet you
someday in person and benefit from
from uh the interaction marwa thank you
so much i'm gonna run off to another
podcast
good luck and see you later bye thank
you